supongamos que tenemos un precipicio
peligroso este va a ser nuestro
precipicio y va a tener una altura de 50
metros si de 50 metros va a estar muy
bien que tenga la altura de mi
precipicio y sobre este precipicio va
conduciendo un automóvil el cual se va a
caer del precipicio esto es un problema
un poco dramático pero aquí está mi
automóvil que va a salir volando por mi
precipicio y este automóvil va a una
velocidad de 5 metros sobre segundo lo
que nosotros vamos a querer son unas
ecuaciones que escriban el movimiento
del automóvil al caer para eso lo que
vamos a ocupar es hacer un dibujo de los
ejes coordinados sobre mi precipicio
entonces voy a suponer que este eje de
verde va a ser mi eje de leyes y este
eje va a ser mi eje de las x perfecto
entonces este va a ser el de las yes le
voy a poner un ahí y este el de las
equis y entonces esta marca de aquí va a
ser 50 porque estamos 50 metros arriba
de la posición original 50 metros arriba
del suelo y supongamos que este punto va
a ser 10 metros es decir que de dónde
empieza el automóvil a andar hasta que
llega al final del precipicio son 10
metros entonces estamos 10 metros
después del origen si nosotros nos damos
cuenta el punto que yo puse de verde
tiene las coordenadas 10 50 y aquí es
donde va a empezar a caer nuestro
automóvil por lo tanto le voy a llamar
que es el tiempo cero y ahora la
pregunta del premio mayor va a ser como
encuentro dos ecuaciones que modelen la
caída de mi automóvil
para sacar este par de ecuaciones
paramétricas una ecuación de xy una
ecuación de ye que dependan del tiempo
voy a ocupar conocimiento de física si
ustedes no se acuerdan nada de sus
apuntes de física o nunca vieron física
sería muy bueno que le echaran un ojo a
mis vídeos de física estas ecuaciones xy
tienen mucha importancia pues cada punto
de mi plano tiene o depende de xy de y
sin embargo lo que voy a hacer es que
cada punto de mi plano depende del
tiempo es decir para cada tiempo va a
haber una posición determinada pero
bueno hablemos de x de t para sacar x de
te voy a suponer que mi automóvil está
en el vacío es decir que no existen
fricción con el aire de hecho voy a
ocupar la primera ley de newton que dice
todo cuerpo se va a mantener el
movimiento a menos que haya una fuerza
que se oponga al movimiento si eso lo
voy a utilizar entonces x dt quien va a
ser pues tenemos una velocidad que va
hacia la derecha de 5 metros sobre
segundo es decir que en cada segundo mi
automóvil se va a mover 5 metros en x
por lo tanto la equis dt va a ser cinco
veces t
pero a esto hay que agregarle la
posición inicial y nosotros no empezamos
en el origen no empezamos en x igual a
cero empezamos en x igual a 10 por lo
tanto en ecuación x dt hay que
aumentarle 10 fíjense que esta es una
buena ecuación de x dt porque si
nosotros pusiéramos que te vale 0
entonces tendremos 5 x 0 + 10 que es 10
es teníamos 10 metros después del origen
x valdría 10 y si nosotros subíamos el
tiempo igual a 1 pues sería cinco por
uno más diez que serían 15 es decir en
el primer segundo estaríamos 15 metros
después del origen o dicho de otra
manera 5 metros después de la posición
inicial muy bien de hecho si ustedes se
dan cuenta esto no es una clase de
física es una clase de matemáticas
entonces este va a ser mi parámetro que
voluntad son esa palabra parámetro es
una palabra muy bonita y de hecho el
parámetro no siempre tiene que ser el
tiempo puede ser el radio o cualquier
otra letra pero bien eso fue en x ahora
le toca el turno a 7 de sacar su
ecuación 7 primero quiero analizar que
estamos a una altura de 50 metros es
decir estamos 50 metros arriba del nivel
del suelo y aparte
ahí va a caer el auto entonces lo
primero que voy a poner 50 y después me
quiero fijar un poco en las fórmulas del
agua fíjense que la velocidad inicial en
10 de este automóvil es 0 el automóvil
no va a brincando ni va buceando ni nada
de eso siempre sencillamente lo vamos a
dejar caer ok pero si nosotros nos
acordamos de las fórmulas del agua había
una que decía agarra la altura inicial
ya la tenemos de 50 a esto suma de la
velocidad inicial por el tiempo pero la
velocidad inicial de nieve vale 0
entonces no es necesario ponerlo ya esto
agrega la aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2
ahorita hablamos de la aceleración pero
lo primero que quiero que vean es que ya
aparece aquí el tiempo al cuadrado entre
2 la aceleración en la tierra si ustedes
se acuerdan es la aceleración de la
gravedad la sedación es la gravedad es
lo que hace que los cuerpos caigan
entonces la aceleración en este caso si
estuviéramos la tierra sería muy cercana
a 9.81 lo voy a notar aquí 9.8 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado
pero para ello quitarme el problema de
cargar siempre con el 9.8 lo voy a
aproximar a 10 entonces va a ser 10
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado es
decir estamos en un planeta con un poco
más de masa que la tierra un poco más
grande con más masa que la tierra pero
ojo en una caída libre la aceleración de
la gravedad es negativa debido a que mi
cuerpo va disminuyendo de altura por lo
tanto voy a ponerle menos 10 de cuadrada
entre 2 menos la aceleración por el
tiempo al cuadrado entre 2 pero creo que
ya fue mucha física por fin ya tengo mis
dos ecuaciones paramétricas tanto x como
ye dependen del parámetro t
es muy fácil recordarlo para cada punto
en mi plan no va a haber un tiempo
determinado para el cual yo esté en ese
punto muy bien de hecho lo que se me
ocurre hacer ahorita es una tabla que
tenga que ver con el tiempo con jay con
x haber voy a hacer otro color la tabla
aquí y va a tener tres columnas una dos
tres muy bien
en el primer columna voy a poner al
tiempo a equis y allí voy a variar el
tiempo para que me den valores de x y
voy a decir que el tiempo puede valer 0
1 2 o 3 y qué pasará con x a ver si yo
sustituyó al tiempo en x y le pongo el
valor de 0 pues me queda 5 x 0 + 10 10 y
si yo pongo 1 pues le queda 5 x 1 + 10
15 5 x 1 + 10 son 15 no
entonces si de hecho son 5 más que el 10
o sea 15 y en el 2 pues es 2 por 5 10 +
10 son 20 entonces voy a poner 20 ojos
se dan cuenta que estoy aumentando de 55
con 3 sería 5 por 315 más 10 25 o sea 5
más que la anterior 25 muy bien
qué pasará ahora con ya pues voy a
sustituir al tiempo aquí pero esto lo
voy a simplificar antes y le voy a poner
que 550 menos 50 cuadrada y ahora sí el
tiempo si hay el tiempo vale 0 pues 5
por 0 0 50 estoy en el punto de inicio
se dan cuenta muy bien ahorita no me
equivocaba ahora si el tiempo vale 1 me
queda 5 por 1 que 550 menos 545 muy bien
me moví poquito pero si el tiempo vale 2
pues es 2 al cuadrado que es 45 por 4
son 20 y 50 menos 20 son 30 entonces sí
te vale 2 pues mi resultado va a ser 50
menos 20 que es 30 voy a ponerlo 30 y si
te vale 3 pues es 3 al cuadrado 3 al
cuadrado es 95 por 9 45 y 50 menos 45 es
550 más 40 y 55 si es imperfecto
bien ya tengo mi tablita ahora voy a
poner estos puntos como si lo estuviera
graficando este es mi primer punto y si
te vale uno pues voy a ponerlo a ver
aquí van a ser cinco diez quince aquí
van a ser veinte aquí van a ser 25 y
ahora en jet de aquí hasta acá son 50 y
cómo va a ir cayendo por eso tengo que
dividir aquí que sea 10 20 30 40 y bueno
50 no perfecto ahora si pongamos dos
puntos si te vale a cero pues estábamos
en el punto inicial en el 10 50 sí te
vale 1 estamos en el 15 45 aquí estamos
este va a ser el tiempo igual a 1 muy
bien qué pasa en el tiempo 2 estamos en
el 2030 o sea 20 en x aquí y 30 en y
justo aquí perfecto estamos aquí cuando
puedan pasado dos segundos en el tiempo
igualados y si estamos en el tiempo
igual a tres pues el 25,5 o sea hasta
aquí es un punto chiquito estamos
cayendo bastante en el tiempo igual a
tres si se dan cuenta esto está casi en
día igual a cero
cuando vas de allí pero si nosotros
ponemos 0 njei pues sería 50 menos 50 y
cuadrada y si yo paso el otro lado el 50
y cuadrada me va a quedar 50 es igual a
50 cuadrada y si yo divido entre 5 me va
a quedar 10 y le saco la raíz me va a
quedar la verdad la raíz de 10 que es
casi 3.1 y ahora si unamos los puntos
bien va a caer para caer y hasta acá
perfecto y ya se dan cuenta esto es una
media para anular nuestro automóvil al
caer traza una forma parabólica es decir
si el automóvil lo dejamos caer hasta
que llegue al suelo nos da una media
parábola pero además de eso nosotros no
estamos dando cuenta de una cosa
padrísima que el automóvil no le queda
de otra más que caer a qué me refiero
con caer así que el automóvil va a salir
del precipicio y como lleva disminuyendo
y x va aumentando entonces va a tomar
una forma parabólica hasta llegar al
suelo y cayendo de esta forma por eso
voy a poner estas flechas wow me
encantan las matemáticas el lenguaje de
las matemáticas te puede decir muchísimo
en este caso me dijeron como que ya mi
automóvil
al salir del precipicio fueron muy
importantes mis dos ecuaciones
paramétricas porque cada una de ellas me
decía cómo estaba el móvil en una
posición en xy en que es decir para cada
tiempo existía un punto es muy plano
cartesiano en el cual iba a estar en ese
tiempo está padrísimo me gustó mucho de
hecho si nosotros tuviéramos un tiempo
cualquiera el que ustedes quieran
supongamos el tiempo igual a 1.5
segundos nosotros tendremos un punto en
el plano al cual va a corresponder ese
tiempo
de hecho imagínense si estuviéramos en
r3 y tuviéramos tres dimensiones pues
por cada tiempo tendremos un punto en el
espacio esto es lo padre de las
ecuaciones paramétricas estoy tan
emocionado que las voy a tratar de verde
y es que déjenme les cuento que cuando
yo vi las ecuaciones paramétricas decía
pues para que complicarlo más la vida y
poner un parámetro de poner unas nuevas
ecuaciones pero las ecuaciones
paramétricas no sirven porque nos dan
una idea de movimiento y varias
aplicaciones en la física en las
matemáticas y en otras ciencias son muy
importantes las ecuaciones paramétricas
pero bueno en lo que vamos digiriendo
esto les cuento que en el siguiente
vídeo voy a hacer una eliminación de
parámetros lo que voy a hacer es que les
voy a dar
que realmente esta curva era una
parábola completa aunque en este caso
solamente por las restricciones físicas
tomemos tiempos positivos ahora
imagínense en una tercera dimensión si
tenemos en el espacio pues tendremos un
buen de trayectorias pero bueno espero
que ahora ya estén suficientemente
motivados para seguir viendo los vídeos
de ecuaciones paramétricas